(cackling)
(screams)
(eerie music)
(yells)
- Ow, you stepped on my toe.
- I apologize.
That was my mistake.
(upbeat music)
- It's Halloween, it's
the best time of year,
everybody knows it.
- Today we're at Knott's
Scary Farm to become monsters
and crawl around in fog and scare people.
- So, we're gonna put on some
effects makeup and costumes,
and become another person entirely.
And for The Try Guys it's gonna really
bring out our inner demon.
(screams)
- My name is John Cook, I
am an entertainment designer
here for Knott's Scary Farm.
We hire about 1,000 people in
and we transform them into monsters.
We teach them everything.
We put them in their costumes, makeup,
to get everything ready and
then we lead to the charge,
get them out there and
just terrifying people.
- How does one become a monster?
- Not only do you have to
apply for a normal job,
then you come down and we
put you through the ringer.
We ask you guys to pretend
you're Satan ordering a coffee,
and we just see how you do.
- I don't like this at all.
- Apparently, Ned is big old baby.
- I'm super afraid of haunted houses.
- I'm also like, " Hey,
Try Guys, let's go watch
"A horror movie!".
Zach goes, "(beep) yeah!"
Keith goes, "All right, I
got nothing else to do."
Ned goes, "Oh, is it rated R?
"Is there gore?"
- However, I do have a theater background.
I think I'll be great with
coming up with character,
getting into the physicality
of it, doing weird voices.
My goal today is to get through
this without getting scared.
- I'm such a friendly guy.
It's tough for me to make
people sad and upset.
- I think Keith is gonna have so much fun.
- My goal is to be the most unique monster
anybody has ever seen in a theme park,
and I want them to scream so loud
that they also fall in love.
- This is honestly a
dream come true for me.
I'm so giddy I cannot control it.
- Zach loves dark (beep), and
I'm rooting for him to really
step up his game and be
bigger than his actual body.
- I'm not a scary person.
I've never intimidate anybody in my life,
so my goal today, I
want to scare somebody.
I want to see when I get in all the makeup
can I inhabit a character,
can I scare some people
the way that I never get to in real life.
- I feel like everyone
says you put a costume on
during October, for me
the other 11 months,
that's when I'm wearing my
costume, my good costume.
- Eugene is kind of just like a demon.
- Literally, a demon.
- I am most excited about
getting in touch with the inner,
crazy Halloween demon that
I know has resided within me
ever since I was a child.
I really want to terrorize
as many people as possible
so that they never forget my demon face.
- So, how do we turn
these four beautiful boys
into four terrifying monsters?
- I don't know, do we even need masks?
- [All] Oh!
- Oh, nice!
- Okay, John!
- You're gonna go through
the transformation process.
We're gonna get you
fitted with some costumes.
- We're gonna fit you in some shirts
and some dusters and vests, okay?
There you go
- [Keith] You and Ned are like twinsies.
- [Zach] Yeah!
- We're eternal twins.
- I cannot show up to Ghost
Town in the same outfit as Ned.
- Forever!
(laughing)
- Looking at us, how would think
we should be crafted into monsters?
- Well, Ghost Town Knott's
Scary Farm is where it started.
We are looking for dead,
decayed ghost town citizens.
The story is that the
green witch cursed people
to runt the streets of Calico as
half human, half animal hybrids.
- She cursed the town of Ghost Town.
And every year at
Halloween time we return.
- We have monsters that
return year after year.
Some have been here for 20 plus years,
and those seem to be the ones that
develop their character the most.
They build their own costumes,
and those become the icons.
- We're gonna become monsters.
Do you have any advice for us
in the transformation?
(evil laugh)
- It comes from in here.
It's more than just putting on a costume.
(growl)
Yes, I've been waiting for him!
- We're gonna pick out some
nice prosthetic appliances
and then we're gonna do all the makeup.
(upbeat music)
- Three, two, one.
(screams)
(evil laugh)
- Oh, my God!
I'm amazing, I'm horrifying.
I'm a monster, it's
what I've always wanted.
- Oh, God!
Look at that!
Oh, look at all those teeth.
I think I'm just gonna be
really excited to meet people,
but I think I might
accidentally scare them away.
I'm really out there to
make friends tonight.
- I look kind of like a
K-Pop star got murdered.
Oh, yeah, I'd (beep) me.
Yeah, you're definitely the scariest.
I'm the only truly scary one here.
(screams)
- I love it!
Never change.
You're beautiful, you're scary.
I'm ready for school.
- All the blood almost makes
me look like I got a dye job.
But a D-I-E job, get it?
- Yeah, we got it.
- It's a pun.
- Guys, meet the pros.
You're gonna give us your
best monster noise, okay?
(growls)
We can do kind a catwalk thing,
we're gonna see your
best monster movements.
All right, there you go.
What scares somebody?
It's a combination of sound and movement,
so let's get those quick startles.
(growls)
(scream)
(laughs)
(yells)
- What about the sliders?
- The sliders, then we have
these guys that go out,
they glue all this metal to them,
they put on knee pads, and
they just run and slide.
And it's a very, very
cool, effective thing.
That's a big thing that started
here at Knott's Scary Farm.
The three main rules, guys,
rules of scare, ready?
No touching, no dirty
talk, no foul language.
- Stupid punk ass kids.
- And don't break character, okay?
- My wife.
- Ready to tear some guests up?
(cheering)
Let's go.
(eerie music)
(cackling)
(yells)
(laughing)
- So, what the (beep) was that?
- Man, this is a lot tougher.
People are really hard to scare.
Half the people act
like they're not afraid,
a quarter of the people try to heckle you.
- Want to play hide-and-seek with us?
- Are you triplets?
- Oh, it's so ugly.
- It's really hard to
actually get a scream.
(yells)
(giggles)
Come on.
- Stupid punk ass kids.
- I am sweating through everything.
I'm exhausted.
- Turns out it takes a lot of work.
It's really hard work.
(yells)
My throat already hurts.
Keith just had (beep) story
time with all the kids.
- I had a little pow-wow with some kids,
had a little story time.
Honestly, that was a failure
because I didn't know
what to with all of them.
I got them on the ground,
I'm like, "Well, now what?"
I don't know.
No!
No, God!
I know that Ned got scared a few times.
(screams)
- Okay.
(Laughs)
okay, now we're having fun.
But oh, man when you
get a total scaredy cat
who's just running away--
(yells)
(screaming)
- Do you hear those screams?
Those are screams of joy.
Those are scream saying
thank you, Try Guys,
for scaring the (beep) out of us.
(yelling)
- What was so great was
working with the other Try Guys
and discovering our demon,
horror personalities.
♫ One little penny
- My demon child, he's
silent, he's creepy,
and he follows you like a rain cloud.
(yells)
- I really liked being a
decoy because I could go and
get someone's attention
and then someone can (beep)
scare them from behind.
(yells)
- I got a few really good slides in
and some really nice scares, too.
(screams)
- I don't know if I was
actually the scariest,
but I think a lot of people
are gonna remember me.
Oh, so little!
- (Beep) you!
(whining)
- We learned an important
lesson here today:
don't challenge Ned to be creepy.
- My bride!
I lure them in and then
(yells)
(screaming)
Stay with me!
It's just fun.
(suspenseful music)
(chattering)
Come back.
I kind of felt a little bad for that girl.
She was almost crying.
I made a girl cry, I feel so bad.
- Well, this was an
absolute dream come true.
Or was it a nightmare?
Same exact thing.
Happy Halloween mother (beep) -ers.
- This was so fun.
I don't know what I was scared of.
- Everybody here is just having fun.
What a job this is.
- It's wonderful.
- You don't think about it,
but it's such a team effort.
All of these amazing makeup
artists, costume designers,
set designers, it's theater.
This is straight up theater.
- To be out here with the
people, to see how much work
goes into it, it was a total honor,
and I'm glad that we could be apart of it.
- Thank you so much to Knott's Scary Farm
and all the wonderful
people who work for it.
Until next time!
(growls)
- [In Unison] Happy Halloween.
(growling)
- I take my coffee like I take my souls.